Speaker 1: OK, let's get into the mailbag
for the week.
Many, many, many, many emails coming in over
the last week.
Only a few can be chosen.
Remember don't abuse info at David Pakman
dot com.
Really, if you're emailing every day, we're
not seeing your emails.
They're getting filtered right into the trash,
actually now into a folder in case law enforcement
ever has a concern about one of our viewers,
it does happen many different topics covered
today in the mailbag.
Let's just jump right in.
What am I even talking about?
Let's start with a message from Peter.
Peter said, Don't underestimate gazpacho.
David, a number of extremist and conspiracy
researchers have brought up the idea that
Marjorie Taylor Greene and Lauren Boebert
gaffes and spelling mistakes are perhaps deliberate
ploys to spread their message further.
It is something to consider, as every time
they make one of these mistakes, it goes viral.
Some point you have to wonder if they're doing
it on purpose to get as many eyes on their
underlying message as possible.
We already underestimated Trump, the buffoon.
Let's not keep making the same mistake.
Thanks, Peter.
Yeah, I think it's completely reasonable to
wonder about that.
I think that there is no way to argue that
these buffoonish gaffes are actually helping
them build support for any of these things.
I mean, the gazpacho thing.
Sure, there are some Americans who have been
sort of tricked or bamboozled into thinking
that there is some kind of vaccine or mask
gazpacho Gestapo.
But there I mean, there people aren't.
They're not really falling for that.
The people who believe that already believe
it, I don't think mis pronouncing it as a
gazpacho is going to bring people into the
movement.
So I don't think that they're that clever.
I don't think that they're that smart.
And even if it's what they're trying to do
to get attention, to convince people by saying
gazpacho instead of Gestapo, I just don't
think it's working.
At the end of the day, and so I'm not, I'm
not worried about that.
Joshua wrote in about Bob Saget, Bob Saget,
the comedian who died not long ago.
We now know the cause of death was some kind
of trauma to his head.
Later went to bed and died, presumably due
to some kind of brain bleed that became fatal
while he was sleeping.
Joshua said So now that Bob Saget cause of
death has been released, don't you think it's
time for Candace Owens to go on TV and apologize
for saying it was due to the COVID vaccine?
Just the thought?
Of course, of course, Candace Owens, the right
wing provocateur, said in the days after Bob
Zagat's death.
We got to be looking at the vaccines here,
and it's not a conspiracy, she said.
We just we got to be looking at the vaccines.
And of course, there was no evidence that
there was a Bob Saget death was related to
the COVID vaccine.
And there's no evidence that some of them
say thousands.
Some say tens of thousands.
Some of them are saying hundreds of thousands
of people are dying from the COVID vaccine.
There's no evidence of any of that.
But someone like Candace Owens doesn't apologize,
and if she were moral and decent, she would.
But there are a whole movement.
I mean, listen, Trump has never apologized
for anything.
Their whole movement is based on not apologizing
and narcissism, something very, very much
present in Trump's personality.
And I would argue to a great degree with Candace
Owens as well.
Narcissists don't apologize.
They don't take responsibility.
It's just what they do.
And we need to.
We need to understand that, Kelly wrote in.
Kelly says.
Does religion make people susceptible to B.S.?
Hey, David, hope you're doing well today.
I'm a frequent listener.
Couldn't help but notice the craziest beliefs
are often held by people who will follow their
unhinged views up with a comment about God
or some aspect of religion.
You've shown many examples of this on your
show.
Do you think holding religious or supernatural
beliefs leads to people being susceptible
to believing other non evidence based views?
Stolen election or anti-vaccine?
Let me know your thoughts.
So.
The answer is yes, and I want to try to sort
of be like respectful in some sense, and I
don't need to make this about religion.
Let me explain what I mean.
We've interviewed on this show experts in
cults, experts in conspiracy theories, experts
in conspiracy ism, the psychology of cults
and conspiracies, and on and on and on.
And they have told us it is very rare that
someone who is eager or susceptible to believe
non empirically based claims like conspiracy
theories are rarely only susceptible to one.
And so the example that's often given as we
often think of flat earth as this kind of
benign, victimless, silly little idea the
earth is flat and it's compartmentalized in
that set.
But as our experts who we've interviewed have
told us and you can find a lot of these great
interviews on our YouTube channel, on our
website.
A lot of the flat-Earthers also believe in,
you know, anti-Semitic conspiracy theories
that Jews control
Speaker 3: the world and
Speaker 1: have mass population control, delusions
or whatever the case may be.
And so we know that it's true.
Now it is up to you to decide whether literal
religious beliefs like there was an arc that
had two of every animal.
And they survived a flood that way.
It's up to you to decide whether that's an
equivalent claim or God would never allow
COVID to be created.
So clearly China did it or whatever.
Believe it's up to you to decide whether claims
like these that involve religion are the same
or not?
It's not for me to tell you, but I think the
trend we see is that when you are willing
to hold or susceptible to believing one type
of non evidence based belief, you're almost
certainly susceptible to holding many of those
types of beliefs.
And there are such beliefs in religion that
fall under that category.
Steve wrote in Steve does not like a phrase
that I used.
He says, Hello, sir.
I'm hoping you could either stop using the
phrase put a pin in that or in stealth.
Instead, say, put that in a pin cushion.
You don't put a pin in something to take a
break from it.
You put your pin in a cushion to come back
to it later.
Please do better, says Steve from Tokyo Steve.
With peace and love.
You're wrong.
The phrase let's put a pin in that to temporarily
stop talking about a subject comes from putting
a pin back in a grenade before it explodes.
OK, now I want to be clear, you know, this
is like I couldn't care less or minus well
versus I might as well.
You know, all these phrases that people get
confused.
The idea here is you take a grenade and you
pull the pin.
Wow.
The grenade is now going to go off.
You've got to resolve that issue because the
grenade will explode.
So when you say, let's put a pin in that,
what it goes back to is, whoa, we don't want
this grenade to explode right now.
We don't know.
We need this grenade.
You put the pin back in the grenade now, many
grenades, you can't actually do that.
But it's the idea is we're not actually going
to blow this up now.
Let's put a pin back in it and then we'll
deal with the grenade later.
That's the source of it.
Steve and I tell this to you with total peace
and love now.
Is it possible that this whole?
Let's put that in a pin cushion.
I've never heard that before.
I'm not saying it doesn't exist, but it sounds
like it's a different phrase.
Different phrase.
OK.
Next, Charles wrote in and said, I'm running
into a lot of pro-Trump propaganda on Tik
Tok and on Instagram Reels.
Yes, and I would go further.
YouTube Shorts is a new vertical video Tik
Tok type format.
It is all riddled with right wing propaganda.
We are aware of this.
We've talked to our YouTube rep about it.
We've talked internally.
We in 2020 to one of the things we're focused
on is growing our tech talk following using
more of Instagram's reels, which are sort
of like a Tik Tok type format and doing a
lot of YouTube shorts because many of you
have written to me and they've said these
formats are dominated by the right.
So one of the things we've been doing, I'm
taking a look at my phone here.
We've been focusing on Tik Tok, where we are
now up to 72000 followers, a million and a
half likes.
We're pushing Tik Tok big because it is.
It is a right wing echo chamber in the political
space.
It's horrible and you're absolutely right,
Charles.
We're going to keep pushing on Tik Tok reels
as well as YouTube shorts.
OK, Shawn wrote in about waning literacy in
the United States.
Shawn says Mr Pacman sir, the depressing level
of literacy on display in your hate mail isn't
limited to David Pakman show rage watchers.
Believe me, Shawn, I know Shawn goes on to
say I've seen equally terrible writing in
various corners of the internet that highlight
social media posts from members of the right.
The Herman Cain Awards subreddit is an obvious
example, but there are many others.
I can appreciate that not everybody is a naturally
gifted writer, but in a developed country
like the United States, it's scary that so
many adults have such a flimsy grasp of the
English language.
Has it always been this bad?
And we're only now seeing it because people
have more public avenues to share their written
thoughts?
Or are we just getting stupider?
My guess is it's a bit of both.
Either way, I only see the problem getting
worse as people continue to demonize public
schooling, teachers science and intellectual
ism.
One hundred and ten percent beautiful email
from Sean.
I think there's two things going on.
I do believe I don't want to say people are
dumber and in fact, by various IQ measures,
it's not true.
But look at videos.
Of and this is always sort of fraught when
you do this, and I know I'm stepping into
a minefield, but look at videos of, for example,
high school and college students asking questions
to the late economist Milton Friedman.
And you will see these.
I'm not going to say the average student because
this is clearly a group that's interested
enough to go listen to Milton Friedman, the
the level of how articulate these these folks
are and how well-spoken they are compared
to what you see when Ben Shapiro visits a
school and takes questions.
It is night and day.
So I think there is a change in terms of how
we sort of expect people to communicate and
grasp on language.
I think that's a part of it.
But the last piece of the email is also very,
very true.
The right has spent decades now demonizing
public education.
Laughing off college is liberal indoctrination
and pushing this anti-intellectual ism all
for their own benefit because they know we're
more likely to convince less educated people
to vote for us because our ideas don't really
make any sense.
They don't.
They don't say this, but this is my interpretation
of it.
So there is an education problem, and it's
a very depressing email that does point to
some major major issues that we are dealing
with.
One other email from Linda.
This is another one of these phrases Linda
says I could care less is a derivative of.
I couldn't care less.
The latter is a direct statement.
The former is sarcasm as if is implied as
an old person.
I remember when people started saying I could
care less.
It was used only informally and was considered
funny.
You had to stop to think and realize they
were saying the opposite of what they meant.
Early on, some people would include the as
if as an as if I could care less.
I think like most ironic expressions, it was
started by some comedian.
The humor went stale.
It sounds stupid.
People who use it will correct it if necessary,
for non fluent speakers of English, so they
know it's ironic or say it out of habit.
If some young journalist wanted to research
this, they could start with standup comedy
in the 60s and 70s.
I had not heard that if this is true, I, as
far as I know the phrases, I couldn't care
less.
And when people say I could care less, they
just don't understand it.
Linda saying there is a historical basis for
I could care less, and it was meant in jest
to mean the opposite of what is said.
Maybe I have not researched it.
I will look into it.
Last email today, Cedric says, Dear David,
I heard the booster shot enlarges the prostate
in black men.
Is that true?
I am an African-American male.
Cedric, I researched this and found nothing
of the sort.
I found nothing that the vaccine affects prostate
size in any man, never mind specifically in
black men.
Check with your doctor if you have any doubts,
but I was able to find no such information.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com.
You'll get instant access to the bonus show.
You'll also get commercial free audio and
video streams of the show available every
day, six hours before the shows are publicly
made available.
Sign up today and you can use the coupon code
Speaker 2: while 22
Unidentified: to get a discount.